thank you
okay uh
um
this is a story about
about uh oh it's a song can you do it
this was your idea right but you're
better at the singing so everyone here
hates me can you please please just do
it here's a little titty about pretty
penny left home for the city she was one
of many got Letters by the sack from her
lonely father but did she write them
back no she didn't bother got one last
letter and the letter said we're sorry
to inform you that your father's dead
so talk to Daddy talk talk to Daddy
isn't a deal but you need to hear so
talk to Daddy talk talk to Daddy now
[Music]
here's what I know about local Landing
with low
[Music]
between you is
daddy daddy
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we go
now
[Music]